[Música]
en el corazón de los viñedos de borgoña
donde los pueblos se llevan nombres de
grandes cruz como pomán nos han george y
sables
se está preparando una fiesta del vino y
no una fiesta cualquiera sino la de
saint vincent hernández una tradición
que se remonta a la edad media
las carreteras están un poco trancadas
llame a la policía pero no viene dos
días antes del festival bernard
vinicultor voluntario y elisabeth
directora de la organización sin ánimo
de lucro están en todos los frentes
buenos dias elisabeth buenos dias
bernard sobrellevar la atención si tu
excelente las calles del pueblo tienen
un aspecto muy diferente dijeron que
bloquearía en la carretera puedes llamar
a michelle y la alcaldía todo está en
marcha ya están los últimos detalles
todavía quedan algunas cosas por hacer
pero poco a poco lo conseguiremos
cada año la última semana de enero se
celebra la fiesta del vino de saint
vincent detonante en diferentes lugares
esta vez los pueblos de guild y les cito
y buyó son los afortunados anfitriones
se esperan 20.000 personas durante los 2
días bernardo encargado de la decoración
debe revisar por última vez necesito más
verdad tienes que ir a buscar algunas a
la alcaldía ya no quedan de plástico
puedo dar listas y usar las otras no tú
también puedes usar algunas hay muchas
michelle decoración sencilla cuatro o
cinco flores es suficiente
6 de la mañana en guild y le citó el
gran día buenos días señora superfecta
ha dormido algo anoche hora y medio a
pesar de lo temprano los participantes
ya están degustando su primera copa de
borgoña podemos tomar café en alguna
parte del café no hoy no hay café para
elisabeth hoy es la culminación de un
año de planificación me emociona cuando
pienso en todo el trabajo que se ha
hecho en estos dos días
queríamos que el festival fuera un éxito
es una oportunidad para que todos los
encontremos para que conozcamos los
vinos de los demás viticultores y para
que los habitantes del pueblo se
conozcan entre sí
todo es cuestión de reconocimiento y
familiaridad
[Música]
nos reunimos todos y nos olvidamos de
nuestras preocupaciones por un día y eso
es maravilloso
a la softbolista vuelve a sixto y solo
[Música]
a mediados del siglo 20 por extraño que
parezca
a los viticultores de borgoña no podían
vender sus existencias
así que para comercializar sus vinos no
vendidos
decidieron revivir una fiesta medieval
de saint vincent 8 de la mañana y el
festival de saint vincent ya está en
marcha
[Música]
antes de que llegue el público los
viticultores
pasarán la mañana desfilando por las
calles entre las bandas y los bailes
populares
los antiguos gremios de ayuda mutua
están representados por un santo y el
estandarte del pueblo vitivinícola una
hora más tarde los visitantes de la
región o de más lejos empiezan a llegar
en trenes
ah
solo hay que seguir la música serán bien
recibidos
es importante saber dónde estamos y
adónde vamos donde venden copas de vino
y dónde están las bodegas
para disfrutar plenamente el festival de
saint vincent se detienen en un puesto y
compran su kit de supervivencia 15
dólares por una copa personal y 7
cupones de degustación aquí están
degustando un gran club un hechizo 2013
pero el clima hace de las suyas a los
gran cruz no les gusta la nieve lo ideal
sería que hubiera uno o dos grados más
de calor pero si lo tiene a la mano
durante unos minutos
acabará teniendo la temperatura adecuada
fuera de su casa bernard un y sirve su
propio vino
como los clubs pero son mejores que
otros lugares de borgoña lamentablemente
no tengo un gran club y un premier club
me encantaría tener un premier cru pero
es muy caro hoy en día a medida que el
festival se acerca a su fin a conferry
de chábeli du cabestany rinde homenaje a
dos ancianos viticultores este año las
mujeres son mayoría
una vez más nos hemos respetado la
igualdad de género porque tenemos cuatro
mujeres y un hombre matan perdiz por no
hemos padres de vida por bach o dios del
vino y por sant vicent
patrón de los viticultores la nombramos
de valientes mamás
[Aplausos]
todos tenían los ojos aguados pero eso
es natural han trabajado toda su vida
esto es una recompensa simbólica
al promocionar tanto los viñedos
pequeños como los de renombre la apuesta
de las fiestas de sant vicent ha dado
sus frutos a la recuperación de una
costumbre medieval